me siento un poco intimidado no lo voy a
negar es que no me golpeen
1 contra 30 seleccionar entre 30 chicas
muy bien empecemos le pedimos a ángel
escoger entre 30 coincidencias
potenciales en persona esto será extraño
seleccionar a la derecha me gusta a la
izquierda no me gusta qué tipo de
aplicaciones de citas a su utilizado he
utilizado varias todas desde kinder
coffee meets bacon bombón no creo que
sea extraño conocer personas en línea
creo que se trata más de abrirte ahora
la posibilidad de conocer a alguien
genial
muy bien vamos a comenzar
vamos a empezar a pasar ganando
la siguiente esto es algo incómodo si
estoy lista
ah
más
[Música]
y
16 coincidencias potenciales me siento
un poco intimidado no lo voy a dejar
si seleccionarán a la izquierda que
significa no me gusta la foto de al sur
se pueden ir
6 compatibles
ángel tiene 30 minutos para conocer a
las chicas
es como enchiladas
con mucho gusto
genial cómo estuvo tu fin de semana cómo
estás bien muy bien
agregó que mi primera pregunta es
pasarías tres horas en la luna o tres
meses en europa los meses en europa
en citas sería estupendo eres de los
ángeles o de huntington
estoy cerca de la universidad del sur de
california estoy el postgrado cuáles son
tus intereses o que te gustaría me gusta
el arte no he visto a mi familia desde
hace mucho tiempo
sí estoy genial práctica si algún
deporte antes practicaba la pasión esto
fue cuando tenía 2 se espera tenías un
blog cuando tenías es una locura
[Música]
si te vas a ir o te vas a quedar por eso
ambas te dan miedo
antes de eso me dio gusto gracias a ti
también que tengas un lindo y gracias a
ver que la pases bien tú también gracias
[Música]
para el estrés de las citas abesbatza
debo escoger uno ahora mismo
es difícil siento que esta es la parte
donde la vida amorosa entra en el mundo
real y cómo tomar esa clase de decisión
decisión final
hola de nuevo
gusto en verte de nuevo genial la pasé
muy bien hablando contigo me gustaría
saber si nos podemos ver otra vez me
encantaría llevarte una cita
eso me encantaría sí genial te diré
cuando dame tu número por si está bien
si yo he divertido
para que tiene así es
esto es extraño extraño es interesante
que uno hace esto todo el tiempo y que
lo he hecho múltiples veces en mi
teléfono pero sin duda es diferente
cuando estás en persona estás como tengo
que hacer esto ahora
definitivamente
haciendo que es muy diferente conocer a
alguien en la vida real incluso en
general normalmente te toma más tiempo
hay mucha más conversación hay mucha más
conexiones pero esto fue o está listo en
5 segundos es tan directo y juzgas a una
persona en 5 segundos
haz clic a la izquierda para suscribirte
a la derecha para ver más vídeos
jubilee